hello and welcome to the agenda here's
hoping you had a good holiday time to
take a look now and what's happening at
the first plenary since the summer break
in his efforts to show solidarity with
Ukraine is the EU poking the bear at the
plenary emmy peas are set to vote on the
eu-ukraine association agreement that
was fast tracked by the Foreign Affairs
Committee in Brussels this week the
agreement creates a free trade zone
between the EU and Ukraine by giving
free market access and abolish 'as
important export duties but how will
Russia retaliate if the trade deal goes
through it's already under a barrage of
sanctions as the international community
tries to get it to withdraw from Ukraine
is another Iraq war on the way hot on
the heels of the NATO summit those
growing political and public support for
an allied military offensive against the
Islamic State of Iraq and an event or
ISIL reborn through the Syrian civil war
in their bid to establish an Islamic
caliphate across Syria and Iraq I saw
has killed butchered and displaced
thousands of a Syrian Christian yazid
ease and Shia minorities MEP s will
discuss the ongoing situation in Iraq
and Syria as well as the role that you
can
we'll all the money go that in the
question in strasburg the council will
present its final draft budget for 2015
is an almighty [ __ ] on the card member
states weren't happy that the Commission
in its original proposal had increased
commitments and payments but if they
were to now reduce spending it will no
doubt anger mepa say we need more money
to spare on growth but it's not just an
issue of growth EU is dance of every 23
billion euros due to unpaid bills that
are rolled over and eaten up funding of
key programs if the 2015 budget is
reduced critics say the same is on the
cards and finally the EU fund for
helping people laid off get back into
work will also be discussed at the
plenary under the European adjustment
fund businesses and member states can
apply for EU funding to help workers
retrain get mentored get educated to
help find their next job at the plenary
applications will be heard from
companies in Romania Spain and the
Netherlands and as though we have for
this agenda take care and see you in
Strasbourg
you